Je vais vous torturer un peu je
vais vous poser des questions
c'est des interviews que nous avons l'habitude de pratiquer
dans cette émission et la première est la
première interview de quelque chose on se
souvient du premier film que vous avez vu l'un
des premiers films que j'ai jamais vu c'était Beauty
et la Bête et certains des Abbott et
Costello et les Trois Stooges et la
première fois est arrivée à peu près celle
que j'aimais Aladdin était
Elizabeth Taylor quand j'étais Gina
Lollobrigida ouais alors ressens autour ouais
ton premier travail bien quand j'étais un  gamin, j'avais l'
habitude d'avoir un petit stand dans la
rue et de vendre des choses de ma maison
dont je voulais me débarrasser comme vous le
savez comme une vente de garage ouais vous
souvenez-vous de votre premier million il y a environ 15
ans ouais pour regarder des films de
The Deer  Chasseur ouais j'ai besoin de savoir où
mourir maintenant quelle sera ta dernière roue si
je devais mourir maintenant je veux juste
m'assurer que tout le monde que je connais et que
j'aime et que je suis là ils sont tous
pris en charge de
la manière  je les voudrais je h  ave ma volonté
faite correctement parce que tu meurs c'est la
dernière déclaration que tu fais aux gens et
c'est très important et ça dure pour le
reste de leur vie donc je voudrais que ce
soit en ordre
ouais d'accord